- The CDC is now recommending
the Pfizer vaccine
for children ages five to 11.
What does that mean?
What are the benefits?
What are the drawbacks?
And how you can help in the
battle against misinformation
with our good friend, the Surgeon
General, Dr. Vivek Murthy.
let's get started, peewoop.
We have a lot to talk about.
- Yes, a lot's happened
since you and I last chatted.
- Yeah, now we have the vaccine
that is more widely available for kids,
and that's a topic I
really wanna dive into.
But first, let's talk about
this misinformation toolkit
that you've published.
Tell me more about that.
- And we did that, not 'cause
how misinformation is new,
but because in the last few years,
we've seen a dramatic increase
in the scale and the
speed and sophistication
with which this
misinformation is spreading.
So, we wanted to call attention to that
and let everyone know
that there were steps
all of us could and needed to take.
And here's why this is so important
because there's a recent
poll that just came out
that showed that close to 80% of people
either believe or think
some of the myths out there
about COVID-19 are actually true.
- What I love about the approach
that's really highlighted in this toolkit
is that you wanna lead with
an empathetic approach.
You wanna be not so much challenging
what people currently believe,
but sort of coming from
a place of understanding
of where they're hearing
it, why they're worried.
- One of the things that we
advocate for in this toolkit
is first, just taking
a pause to understand
what people's motivations are,
what their concerns are,
what's important to them.
If we don't take an empathetic approach,
if we don't give people
the benefit of the doubt
before we judge or shame
them, then we lose them.
We don't have the
opportunity to support folks
in reaching that shared goal.
I haven't heard of a single person's mind
who's been changed by
being shamed or blamed.
So, the bottom line is
those approaches don't work.
- Yeah, tell me what
vaccine has been authorized
by the FDA, under the EUA,
and what are the steps
that parents should take
to getting this vaccine for their kids.
- Well, I'm glad we're talking about this
'cause this is a landmark moment
not just for parents like me
who have kids five through 11,
but for all of us
who wanna see this
pandemic come to an end.
With the recent FDA authorization
and the CDC recommendation of the vaccine
for kids five through 11,
and this is the Pfizer vaccine, mind you,
we now have 28 million children,
28 million more people,
who have come under the umbrella
potentially of being vaccinated.
But here's what parents
really need to know.
Number one,
the vaccine was rigorously
tested in clinical trials
and it was put through
the same review process
by the FDA and CDC that we
put any other vaccine through.
And what they found in that review process
was that this vaccine
was highly effective,
more than 90% effective,
at protecting our kids
from symptomatic COVID.
The second thing they found
is that the safety profile
of the vaccine was actually
really, really good.
And when children did have side effects,
they were a sore arm, fatigue,
a headache, occasionally a fever,
but those symptoms went
away within a day or two,
and what the children were left with
was longer-term protection.
And very importantly,
they did not see any
serious adverse effects.
- Do you view this authorization
for five to 11 year old
as a potential off-ramp
for some of the residual mask
mandates that still exist,
whether it's in schools, in hospitals?
- Okay, well, so I think the
more people get vaccinated,
the more we have a chance of getting cases
to come down and stay down,
and then that's really gonna be our key
to an off-ramp with things like masks
and other restrictions as well.
Kids, in addition to getting COVID-19,
also can spread COVID-19.
There was a notion out there before
that kids don't transmit the virus.
We absolutely found that is not the case.
They do transmit the virus,
they contribute to spread.
And so, yes, getting 28 million
more children vaccinated
will absolutely help reduce the spread,
help get cases down, keep 'em down.
And that's when we can start to get rid of
some of the restrictions that
we currently have right now.
- How does getting your child
vaccinated protect grandma?
- Oh, great question.
We know, again, that children
can transmit the virus,
that has definitely been proven.
We also know that when
children then see folks
who are vulnerable like
grandparents, for example,
especially those who
have not been vaccinated,
there's a real risk they can
pass on the virus to them.
And that's important
because we've seen the
vast majority of deaths
that have taken place from COVID-19
has occurred among the elderly
population, those above 65.
And finally, Mike, I think it's important
that we recognize one thing
that COVID has taught us, right,
is that our health really does depend
on what other people do, right?
- Yeah.
- And what we've learned from
other viruses and illnesses
in the past is the more
of us get vaccinated,
the more of a wall we build
around those who are vulnerable.
- Yeah, and a very specific question
that I see come up quite
often on social media
and from my patients is on
the topic of myocarditis,
the inflammation of the heart.
We didn't even see that
in the Pfizer study
for five to 11 year olds.
Do you think the study had
sufficient participants
to rule that out?
And if it does happen, what does it mean?
How does it compare to getting myocarditis
from actual COVID-19?
- The trial that was done
for kids five through 11
had several thousand
children in it, right?
So, they were able to detect side effects
that would happen with
any reasonable frequency.
And thankfully, they didn't see
any serious adverse effects.
Now, is there a chance that there could be
a very rare side effect that crops up?
There's always that chance,
but everything we do is
a risk-benefit, right?
And what we have to compare
the risk of any vaccine to
is to the risk of getting COVID itself.
And there, what we do know
is that people who get COVID
do have a significantly higher risk
of actually having cardiac
involvement like myocarditis.
We also know that they
have a risk of blood clots,
they have a risk of on COVID,
and a whole host of other issues,
which you don't see with vaccines.
- I think the reality of
how prevalent COVID is now
in our society that
you're basically choosing
between getting the vaccine and
getting COVID at this point.
Because I don't think
there's a child out there
who you can say they probably
won't experience COVID.
I think that it's so prevalent
that you're almost having
to make the choice,
it's between the vaccine or COVID.
And in that case, if you
look at the myocarditis
that has happened in the slightly
higher age range for kids,
it's been so few in comparison
to getting myocarditis from COVID-19,
you're essentially making the decision
between one of two paths.
And we wanna make the
path of least disease,
least infection, least complications.
And COVID-19 has a lot of
complications, as you said.
So, really, that's the
take-home point for parents.
How do you see this
misinformation playing out
with the topic of
infertility for children?
Because that's something a lot
of parents are worried about
because their children five to 11
don't have that issue at
that point, obviously,
but then, later in life,
is that something you're concerned about,
even perhaps for your own children?
- Yeah, I'm glad you raised it
because there are about
1/3 of folks out there
who either believe or are unsure
about this myth around infertility.
The truth is that there is
nothing in the data that we have,
in the science, that lends
any credence to that rumor.
There is no link between
the vaccine and infertility.
And that's actually why I'm getting
my five-year-old vaccinated, too.
Because, of course, I want
him to have a healthy future.
I want him to be healthy in all ways.
I would love for him to
have a family one day,
if he wants to, but I'm not concerned
that the vaccine is gonna
inhibit any of that.
If anything, I feel the vaccine
will give him a greater shot
of leading a healthier life
and not having complications from COVID,
and that's what we all want as parents.
- What's your guidance on
receiving the COVID-19 vaccine
for your five to 11 year old
and getting other
vaccines at the same time?
- The good news is you can
get other vaccines as well.
It's very important to
get vaccinated for flu,
you just need to get
it at a different site.
So, we have two arms, so we
can get a shot in each arm.
- (laughs) What would you tell parents
who have an 11 year old who's
close to her 12th birthday?
Should they wait for
the 30 microgram dose?
- Yes, I would say don't wait.
I'd say go ahead and get your dose now
and if your child is 11,
they'll get 10 micrograms.
If they're 12 by the time they're
due for their second dose,
then they'll get 30
micrograms at that point.
But the reason not to wait
is that you don't wanna delay your child
starting to build protection.
And they will start to build protection
with that 10 microgram dose.
Especially with as much
COVID as we have circulating,
the faster kids get protected, the better.
- Are there any children
that you would recommend
to not get vaccinated or hold
off waiting to get vaccinated?
- So, I would say the only reason
to hold off getting vaccinated
is if you have a specific allergy
to a component of the Pfizer vaccine.
That's very rare, people
generally don't have that.
But if you have an allergy
to foods or to eggs,
for example, or other things,
you don't need to avoid
getting vaccinated.
We want people to go
ahead and get vaccinated.
- Yeah, I think a lot of patients
and parents have questions.
If their child has a unique condition,
whether it's a platelet
condition, some other allergy,
perhaps a heart condition or
diabetes runs in the family,
and they get worried if their
child is at a higher risk
to having side effects,
is any of that true?
- Well, so generally, we
haven't seen any concerns
with children with
other medical conditions
getting the vaccine.
That's good news.
In fact, I would say the flip is true,
which is if you have
other medical conditions,
then we know from our
experience with COVID,
that increases the risk
of you having bad outcomes
if you get COVID-19.
So, in my mind, it's actually
all the more important
for children with other medical conditions
to get vaccinated to protect them against
the bad outcomes of the virus.
One of the things that's
really important, I think,
is for us to recognize that
getting our kids vaccinated
is also about helping to address
the profound mental health toll
that our kids have sustained
over the last 20 months.
Rates of anxiety and
depression and loneliness
rise among any groups of children.
And this is so sad to see
and it's heartbreaking,
but we can do something about it.
That's where the vaccine is so helpful.
- It's a very holistic approach
and a as a family medicine doctor
who's also an osteopathic
physician by training,
I very much appreciate you
thinking in those terms.
- And I'm really hopeful,
also, at this moment.
And I know that sometimes
you read the news
and it can feel like it's
doom and gloom all the time,
but there are so many reasons
at this particular point
in time to be hopeful.
We have not just one, but
three vaccines available.
We have 190 million plus people
who have been fully vaccinated.
We have our kids back in school.
We have vaccines for kids five through 11,
and we're finding ways to
get back to our way of life,
but we can only do it together.
And that's why it's not just about doctors
like me and you having conversations,
it's about people recognizing
the power they have
because of their voice,
because of their trusted relationships.
They can be the person
who makes a difference
in someone else's
decision to get protected
by getting vaccinated.
- Dr. Murthy, thank you
so much for educating us,
empowering us to help my
viewers and myself and my family
to make the right
decisions about our health.
And I hope we continue meeting
up with this misinformation.
We have a toolkit now that
I can arm my residents with,
community leaders with, and
we continue to thank you
for the work that you've been doing.
So, thank you for that.
- I so appreciate that, Mike.
- I had a difficult patient encounter,
click here to check that out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(gentle bass music)